pronto pronto benissimo ma io da 40 anni
mi occupo di aziende recentemente degli
amici che comincia ad avere i capelli
bianchi
mi hanno detto che erano molto
preoccupati perché loro figli non
trovano lavoro e danno la colpa alla
crisi e allora io ho scritto questo
saggio un paio d'anni e o copio scoperto
che la crisi non c'entra niente
ho scoperto che in tutto il mondo il
riso quei giovani neo laureati o
diplomati e faticano molto di più degli
altri a trovare lavoro ma che in italia
siamo abbiamo il record di questa
disgrazia per ogni gioco per ogni
disoccupato ce ne sono 3,532 3 3,5
disoccupati peggio della grecia è
un'informazione terrificante
nessuno lo sa e nessuno ne parla perché
è successo è successo per una ragione
molto semplice se la crisi non c'entra
questo avanti da dieci anni è successo
perché il lavoro è cambiato e la scuola
è rimasta quella del secolo scorso
perché il lavoro è cambiato ma che parla
tanto di digitale ma in realtà è
chiaramente web design web marketing
data analysis sono dei lavori molto
interessanti del futuro ma rimarranno
una nicchia rimarranno una nicchia
perché perché fondamentalmente quello
che è successo che non cambiano i lavori
ma cambia in modo con cui si lavora
huber ha rivoluzionato il modo con cui
si fa il taxi ma la benedetta rese in
questi due anni e che era già tubero in
italia assunto cinque persone il
digitale un grandine blair ma sotto c'è
qualcosa di molto più profondo che sta
cambiando il modo con cui si lavora
perché non è stato tanto capito e questo
qualcosa e il passaggio da un'economia
industriale a un'economia post
industriale post industriale
perché il lavoro che noi conosciamo per
lo meno quelli che hanno i capelli
bianchi come me e questo è la fabbrica
con gli operai e gli stanzoni privi di
impiegati siamo passati a un mondo in
cui l'economia con i miei servizi questo
è un grande servizio telecomunicazioni
trasporti turismo e non ci sono più
tanti operai e tanti impiegati che
eseguono le procedure che qualcuno dice
per loro ci sono tanti capi che devono
interagire col mondo è cambiato quello
che si chiede sul lavoro e allora come
ti ci porto tutto questo alla t che è la
mia idea che vorrei difendere e
diffondere le migliori scuole d'europa
sono in finlandia
eppure oscillandia da cinque anni hanno
capito quello che io sto raccontando e
hanno lanciato un progetto che si chiama
oiv all'us oiv allo sport e lo valussi
ha sondato a parlare di milano racconter
mandato e l'extra bellissima immagine di
come cambia il mondo del lavoro il
21esimo secolo sembra un orchestra di
jobs non c'è il direttore d'orchestra e
non ce lo spartito ognuno improvvisa
poi viene la melodia però il vallo 6
reti citato un'altra bellissima idea che
quella che vorrei diffondere kelati per
che cosa diceva lui ci guardate le
competenze del passato sono quelle che
si insegnano a scuola sono le competenze
cognitive lever da parte verticale a
questo ragazzo che cos'è e chiaro che
uno vuol fare il progettista meccanico
deve conoscere sapere prese dalle
macchine uno può fare il ragioniere dove
conoscerà contabilità sos turista deve
saper programmare questo è la competenza
cognitiva che quella che sia insegnata a
scuola che si insegna oggi disegnare
bene o male ma eva luz ha aggiunto
un'altra cosa ha detto queste cose non
bastano più per il lavoro del xxi secolo
ha raggiunto questa parte orizzontale
questa giovane che si apre e questa
parte orizzontale che cosa vuol dire io
l'ho chiesto ai datori di so anche che
la mia esperienza e il datore di lavoro
non ride è chiarissimo e quello che
vogliono la prima cosa che cedono e
quella che chiamano l'etica del lavoro
cosa vuol dire e l'etica del lavoro vuol
dire non rubare no se presuppone avevo
vuol dire senso di responsabilità andare
oltre i propri compiti spirito critico
c'è un compito che devo fare che non si
può fare meglio lo propongo io di fare
meglio
poi chiedono problem solving chiedono
che non si parli di teoria ma si parla
dal problema e si arriva utilizzando la
teoria poi siedono la capacità di
comunicare 75 per cento del tempo sul
lavoro oggi si passa comunicando
interagendo con clienti con colleghi e
che cosa vuol dire saper comunicare vuol
dire saper ascoltare e poi chiedono il
timore la capacità di lavorare con gli
altri vuol dire ognuno alla propria
specializzazione ma in grado di
contribuire alle altre specializzazioni
e poi il concetto che è stato detto
prima
l'empatia che le assenze di tutto questo
questa è la tv allora l'ha detta il
check in dell'aeroporto che aveva visto
prima quando cancellano un volo non può
chiamare caposcalo deve cavarsela da sè
deve improvvisare per risolvere problema
del cliente addetto al call center di
sky o di vodafone
quando voi chiamate spesso i clienti
sono maleducati i pazienti deve
ascoltarli con pazienza e risolvere il
loro problema e spiegarglielo bere
questo è il mondo del xxi secolo
l'attenzione non sono competenze del
lavoro sono competenze per la vita
perché secondo non ha queste competenze
non può essere un buon genitore un buon
elettore è un buon cittadino allora come
si costruisce latina ma i finlandesi
sulla parte verticale sono bravissimi
perché quello che è successo in questi
15 anni che la capacità di insegnare
bene in profondità non ha memoria
capendo si può misurare
attraverso i test pisa simile ai test
invalsi anni migliori pisa d'europa
quindi in effetti su questo loro non è
che hanno molto da da imparare però
hanno deciso che bisogna avviarsi e con
loro tante scuole nel mio del mondo a
prepararsi aggiungere la parte
orizzontale e ci sono una serie di
sperimentazioni molto importante partire
abbiamo sentite che per esempio il fatto
che la classe non è più quella del
secolo scorso
praticamente la lezione frontale c'è ma
sempre meno grazie a computer uno vede
la lezione a casa poi cosa fa
interagisce in progetti dalla indosso al
modulo schooling la scuola industriale
tutti allineati dietro alla classe
interattiva e poi si sta cominciando a
capire che cosa vuol dire la vera scuola
lavoro per esempio si comincia a capire
che la prima di stato tedesco 2 per
cento di tasso gigi corpo disoccupazione
giovanile
i giovani turno a tutti lavoro non è
come lo abbiamo pensato non andare a
imparare in fabbrica come si usa antonio
efab e che rappresentano pochissimo si
tratta di servizi anche le assicurazioni
le banche ma poi non imparano una
tecnica tanto le tecniche sono obsolete
in pochissimo tempo la tecnologia cambia
imparano a lavorare con gli altri e non
fanno uno stage come da noi stanno metà
tempo tra i 14 e 18 anni a scuola sul
lavoro
e i datori di lavoro che a quel punto ho
solo se vi piace li assumono
non sta cambiando solo la scuola sta
cambiando l'università nel mondo c'è una
rivoluzione nelle università stanno
nascendo dell'università orientate al
mondo del lavoro
beniamino di ingegneria delle datori di
lavoro americani non è più che mai ti e
olen college e pauline college e
università triennale in ingegneria nata
dieci anni fa dove non ci sono più
scuole salta lezione frontale ma sono
progetti interazione si studia
ingegneria
una storia dell'arte musica
imprenditorialità e i ragazzi sono molto
molto ricercati quindi una vera
rivoluzione
viene naturale dire come lati da noi
così così
io ho fatto fare dei sondaggi ho fatto i
sondaggi i nostri datori di lavoro
e i nostri giovani sono i più scontenti
d'europa sulla capacità della scuola
prepararsi al lavoro
lo stesso sondaggio fatto agli
insegnanti dice che gli insegnanti sono
molto soddisfatti di come prepara ogni
giorno di lavoro
chi ha ragione chiediamo vediamo come ce
lo spiega lati ce lo spiega lati molto
chiaramente che ha ragione i primi e
molti docenti che capiscono anche loro
che la cosa non funziona la nostra è la
parte verticale quindi come insegniamo
la conoscenza come sia insegnato negli
ultimi 20 anni è mediocre
nella media siamo dove dovremmo essere
attraverso i testi ma quello che è
drammatico da noi e che ci fa una
vergogna e l'enorme differenza che c'è
al nord siamo a livello della finlandia
della polonia al sud siamo a livello di
cipro della bulgaria
io ieri ero a napoli a parlare di queste
cose e ho percepito che si convince a
capire e poi c'è differenza fra i cesti
tutto tecnici molto più che negli altri
paesi e c'è differenze fra scuola scuole
enormi più che in tutti gli altri paesi
differenze poi però c'è anche vorrei
anche dire la nostra buone scuole
insegnano la parte verticale conoscitiva
bene non possiamo lamentarci per un po
vecchiotto molte nozioni un po memoria
si studia tantissimo però va bene non
possiamo lamentarci
il quello che è veramente drammatico e
la dimensione orizzontale
i dottori di lavoro vogliono l'etica del
lavoro
l'etica del lavoro vuol dire ed etica
dello studio vuol dire la serietà della
scuola e purtroppo in molte scuole si è
persa
il senso di responsabilità noi siamo il
recordman dopo i turchi delle assenze
ingiustificate a scuola i voti non vuol
dire più nulla ai datori di lavoro al
sud ci sono il doppio dei 100 lo della
maturità il 70 per cento degli studenti
e anche degli insegnanti credono che i
voti non significano niente la scuola ha
perso la capacità di certificare in
merito e quindi ha perso il senso di
responsabilità e di meritocrazia che
quello cedono che quello i datori di
lavoro però però però non è solo questo
la didattica che abbiamo visto è
totalmente industriale fa difficoltà a
partire io vedo un sacco di
sperimentazione anche in questi due
giorni vedo un sacco ma il cambiamento è
difficilissimo perchè perchè io ho
parlato ci sono in italia c'è un
progetto chiamano la vanguardia
educativa bisogna cambiare completamente
l'orario di lavoro perché i ragazzi devo
andare a scuola anche il pomeriggio come
succede in tutta europa però i nostri il
contratto di lavoro prevede che i nostri
insegnanti lavorino 18 ore alla
settimana contro 30 in germania sono
pagati di più non si potrà fare quello
che è stato visto fino a che la buona
scuola non farà veramente una grande
rivoluzione in questo senso che non è
prevista la scuola lavoro
i datori di lavoro dicono che purtroppo
pochi star pochi stage per fare
fotocopie l'università
l'ocse venuta fuori con dei dati
terrificanti un paio di giorni fa
abbiamo un buon e molte meno buone che
non preparano lavoro con tassi di
disoccupazione micidiale ma soprattutto
e questo sulla parte verticale
dell'atteso la parte orizzontale le
migliori università come politecnico di
milano la bocconi che sono buone non
perché hanno buoni insegnanti ma perché
selezionano bene gli studenti hanno
difficoltà anche loro
al lavoro ci sono poche intership ca
foscari è una delle poche che ha
lanciato programmi di interesse i
ragazzi arrivano tardi sul mercato del
lavoro 27 anni contro 22 la media
europea
27 contro 22 l'inflazione dei dati in
meta dei ragazzi che si laureano si
laureano con più di 100 ma il mio libro
però stato detto un manuale di
sopravvivenza io dico dimenticate tutto
questo per dieci anni se qualcosa
succederà la buona scuola arriverà fra
dieci anni
cosa possono fare i giovani oggi primo
scegliere le proprie passioni o qualcuno
ha parlato di passione non quelle dei
genitori
oggi si sceglie sulla base delle
passioni dei genitori due scegliere le
scuole le università migliori e le
scuole università non sono tutte uguali
non c'è trasparenza oggi dal ma si può
ricostruire io spiego come farlo rivelo
saggi può capire anche capendo chi è il
preside se presi da bravo un preside
bravo fa la differenza in italia abbiamo
8.000 preside ci saranno mille bravi
capiamo quali sono lavorando durante di
studio e non prima studio poi lavoro
come si dice in tante famiglia prima si
studia poi si lavoro poi si va presto
sul mercato del lavoro non tardi cercare
la diversità degli amici non frequentare
solo gli amici perché sono aprendosi
magari andando all'estero si capisce
quella diversità che l'essenza del
keyword dell'innovazione e poi
scegliendo le aziende che formano
all'ati aziende che stimolano e che
sanno stimolare i giovani in questo
senso va bene spero di essere quindi
riuscito a convincere in questi pochi
minuti di quanto questa t e la
diffusione di questa ti sia così
importante da diffondere la società
italiana presso datori di lavoro doccia
insegnanti e famiglie per il futuro dei
nostri giovani
grazie